منذ تفشي فيروس كورونا اختار احمد القاضي
التمسك بقطاع السياحه الذي عمل به على
مدار 20 عاما وبدا يعمل من المنزل هو
وزملائه في الشركه الامر الذي استمر حتى
مع عوده تدفق السائحين الى مصر وانتعاش
القطاع
عمله عن بعد جعله يقدر قيمه تجارب الدول
اخرى في ضبط ايقاع القطاع السياحي
والترويجي للسياحه من خلال المنصات
الالكترونيه
عملت
شغل كويس بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
للمنصات والحاجات اللي انت بتعملها نفسي
نبقى نوصل او نعمل حاجه زي كده لان همم
هتساعد جدا المركب في مصر او تساعد
البرودكت ان هو يطلع لنور في مصر وفي نفس
الوقت مصر اولادي في الفتره اللي جايه دي
واحده جدا ان هي تقدر تاخذ ماركه شركه
كويس من سحره الخارجيه ال ال الاجنبيه
دراسه حكوميه تحمل اسم المؤشر العام
لبروميتر السياحه اظهرت تفاؤل مجتمع
الاعمال بمستقبل القطاع السياحه في مصر
هذا تفاؤل تعاكسه نسب اشتغالات مرتفعه في
معظم الفنادق والمقاصد المصريه خاصه في
هذا الوقت من العام ولكن للوصول للمستهدف
30 مليون سنه سنويا خلال هذا العقد يرى
خبراء السياحه انه يتعين على الحكومه
المصريه ان تتخذ عدد من الاجراءات الداعمه
على القطاع
[موسيقى]
دينا خطاب تروج للسياحه من والى مصر عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولها متابعون
كثير وهي ايضا تعمل من خلال شركه سياحه
مرخصه تمتلكها وترى ان هناك الكثير الذي
يمكن للقطاع من خلال شباب العاملين الذين
يفكرون خارج الصندوق بحسب قولها
همم كطاع سياحه متفائلين جدا يعني مثلا
شركات السياحه دلوقتي ترخيص شركات سياحه
مقفول الناس بتبقى قاعده عندنا هنا جوه
مصر وبتعرف تجيب من جميع دول العالم وتقول
زوروا مصر همم فندي امكانيه للناس دي ان
هي تشتغل وتفتح نفتح لهم بس الرخصه همم
ونخليهم يشتغلوا بشكل اوضح فيه فكر عظيم
هنا همم يعني مدفون فعلا محتاج بس مساعده
او دعم الدراسه الحكوميه تستعرضه توصيات
الخبراء ومنها تبسيط واجراءات تاسيس
المشروعات السياحيه وتخفيض الرسوم عليها
وتدريب العاملين بالقطاعه بالاضافه الى
رفع الوعي السياحي واحكام الرقابه لحسن
التعامل مع السائح والترويجي للمقصد
السياحي المصري تامر نصره العربيه القاهره